We've already learned about Athena's
internship at the architecture firm.
But she also has another part-time job,
tutoring.
Her job at the firm pays her $2000 every
month.
So, let's use a function to represent the
total amount that she makes from this job
in x months.
That will give us f of x equals 2,000 x.
She makes about $1,000 a month from
tutoring.
So, we can say that g of x, the total
amount of money she's made from tutoring,
equals 1,000 x.
Where x is still number of months.
So, how much does Athena make, in total
each month?
Now if we say that h of x, is equal to
the total amount of money, that Athena
has made after x months, then what
expression is that equal to?